ça fait des mois qu'on n'avait pas vu
autant de Russes oser dénoncer la guerre
à voix haute de Moscou aikaterinbourg en
passant par Saint-Pétersbourg ils ont
envahi les rues des centres-villes en
quelques minutes ils étaient chassés ou
brutalement arrêter
non à la guerre ce cri étouffé réprimé
par le régime de Vladimir Poutine depuis
le 24 février non à cette guerre que des
centaines de milliers de Russes devront
désormais mener fusil à l'épaule contre
leurre de 14 minutes à la nation
Vladimir Poutine a annoncé la nouvelle
la mine basse et l'air grave au premier
épisode il est nécessaire et urgent
procéder à une mobilisation partielle je
répète partiel à déclaré Poutine mais
même partielle c'est l'équivalent de 300
000 hommes d'un bout à l'autre du pays
qui ont un minimum d'expérience
militaire des jeunes comme Georgie que
nous avons joué à Moscou
il est déjà reçu une convocation et
s'est rendu au bureau d'un roulement
avec son père tel coordonnées sous peine
d'amande par le ministère de la Défense
il est un étudiant de 23 ans il n'a
aucune expérience en infanterie
à l'entraînement le 26 septembre raconte
Georgie ils ont modifié mes
qualifications pour m'envoyer au front
pour tuer des gens du type
il n'a pas les moyens de quitter la
Russie comme le
le prix des billets pour un aller simple
en Arménie par exemple ont plus que
quintuplé
idem pour la Turquie et l'Azerbaïdjan là
où les Russes peuvent se réfugier sans
visa pour au moins un
[Musique]
ange
to free la seule façon d'échapper cette
s'enfuir du pays tout de suite il n'y a
aucune autre alternative du Denise
bilunov un opposant au régime et
fondateur du Comité antigaire
qui est perçue comme un aveu d'échec une
preuve de la faiblesse de l'armée russe
c'est un Vladimir Poutine défiant qui
s'est adressé aux Russes
l'Occident essaie de détruire notre pays
et ne s'en cache même plus à dire
Vladimir Poutine qui s'apprête à nexer
des territoires en Ukraine qu'il
considérera partie intégrante de la
Russie
l'intégrité territoriale du pays menacé
il n’hésitera pas à utiliser tous les
moyens à sa disposition pour protéger la
Russie
ceci n'est pas un bluff à 10 Poutine
mais en quoi envoyer des jeunes sans
expérience au front changera quelque
chose
puis pourquoi
[Musique]
la guerre vient de passer à une autre
étape encore plus dangereuse et
imprévisible qu'elle ne l'était déjà
ici Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada
Montréal